[Musique]
pourquoi
voici tout le jeu spécial télé avec
coluche présentateur dans coluche info
[ __ ] de camion pour le chat le tube
télé de l'été 92 les rita c'est comme ça
catherine en speakerine plus le
caméraman rang d'affilée sont bâtis
chaud la maquilleuse chantal ladesou
évadés du théâtre du musée grévin le
super expert françois rollin alias
professeur rollin et le dj philippe
corti le meilleur du pays plus patrick
sébastien michel denisot et françois de
closets voici tout le jeu spécial télé
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
et non je ne suis pas aux folies
bergères ce soir je suis à la martinique
à fort-de-france plus exactement
la france n'est pas seulement la
métropole ce sont aussi ces petites îles
au grand coeur et il est dans la mission
du service public d'aller au moins une
fois par an embrasser ces hommes et ces
femmes qui nous regardent chaque semaine
civile
je ne suis pas vraiment tu dis c'est la
télévision c'est un fossé intox et même
le sujet de double jeu un double jeu
consacré ce soir à la télévision
com
et
là
mais non
alors on va commencer par un mini débat
en forme d'interview parallèle c'est à
dire que je vais vous poser à tous les
trois la même question à tour de rôle
alors on entend dire toute la journée la
télévision n'est plus ce qu'elle était
alitée quoi la télévision avant je pense
qu'elle était moins bien c'est tout ce
qui est nostalgie le magnifie toujours
franck cellier parce que avant ça
correspond à une époque on était plus
jeunes donc on pense que c'était mieux
c'est vrai pour tous et la télévision
quand on ressort des séquences ancienne
on se rend compte qu'il ya de bonnes
choses mais c'était quand même fait avec
des bouts de ficelle avec un rythme lent
même les grands reportages on a toujours
la nostalgie sainte colome quand on
ressort des reportages cinq colonnes bon
c'était magique à l'époque et
aujourd'hui c'est plus magique c'est
simplement un outil de consommation
comme le réfrigérateur mais c'est rien à
voir françois bès était la télévision au
menu et pour le restaurateur c'est ce
qu'il ya de meilleur
parce qu'on sait redevenu et puis tout
le monde doit être content maintenant
c'est à la carte
et puis ils se lèvent et viennent pas
pour quitter le restaurant s'est appuyé
sur un bouton et fiche le camp alors
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à faire
c'est probablement meilleur pour le
téléspectateur a été quoi la télévision
avant alors vous êtes sûr que line
renaud était moins bien avant toi dedans
quand on regarde bien les documents
qu'est ce qui t'a choqué récemment dans
l'univers de la télévision ou j'aime pas
les reality show tu devrais c'est
vachement bien
françois ce qu'est dans la télévision
récemment dans l'univers la télévision
qu'est ce qui t'a choquer mais ce qui
m'a choqué c'est ce qu'on voit à l'heure
du repas
mais c'est une bonne chose de choquer
les gens leur mangin montrant qui a pas
seulement ce qui est dans leurs
assiettes
mais il ya des moments où c'est dur de
manger en regardant le journal
mais c'est très bien et toi ben j'aime
pas les reality show pas pour les
reality show eux mêmes c'est pour la
libye de coeur et d'humanité qui a
derrière c'est à dire que ces mecs
arrivent en disant vous savez que notre
mission c'est la générosité c'est le
coeur comme si en dehors des reality
shows on n'avait pas de générosité de
coeur si longtemps de générosité de
coeur que ça ils font pas voir les
accidents il invite juste les mecs et
ils les font applaudir sa frappe a
beaucoup d' écoutes sauvages
ouais mais ou alors qu'il dise on va
vous montrer des flexibles bon on sait
où on va mais c'est la libye qui me gêne
tu vois la libye générosité que canto
nodimat baise tu as peur pas vraiment
que je suis sur une île par rapport au
paysage audiovisuel français c'est vrai
sur canal c'est différent nous notre
notre vrai baromètre c'est pas le
mediamath même si on le regarde comme
tout le monde mais c'est pas vital à
cannes à l'envi des abonnements et le
vrai baromètre c'est le taux de
réabonnement c'est les gens se
réabonnent ça veut dire que ça fait là
ça va on est à 90 7 %
toi tu as peur quand on a dix mois de
baisse et toi oui toi oui bien sur wii
bonsoir moi j'ai supprimé quand mon
audimat bc c'était principalement en fin
d'émission quand la tienne démarrer donc
c'était positif sans toi comme tu es mon
ami ça me faisait vachement plaisir
quelles sont les critiques concernant
que tu estimes juste distant ou un peu
froid
ouais c'est ça qui revient le plus
souvent cela me paraît juste souvent par
trois avec les mains trop qui ont dit
laisse parler les autres mais quand on
laisse parler les autres au bout d'un
moment on dépasse alors on nous dit vous
faites une demi heure de trop et toi
robe classique vulgaire vulgaire parle
trop de cul ferait mieux de fermer sa
gueule de temps en temps chez de
l'ouvrir et cetera et cetera sur projets
non
et toi vulgaire parle trop de cul les
mêmes si tu veux y at il une émission
dont tu es franchement jaloux le
confessionnal ouais franchement pas ce
que c'est les idées appartiennent à ceux
qui les réalisent
et puis il a fait bien donc je peux pas
le faire et c'est un truc que j'aurais
aimé faire je continue à le faire sur
l'axé sur le trio mais qui copient
saliba fille en curé j'ai vu l'autre
jour peut aussi faire ça ne va pas sur
canal pas sur france 2 pourquoi je sais
pas quelles émissions et du gel ou
françois il ya un type qui est une idée
géniale je commence à peine une émission
ces infos intox
seulement moi je voudrais faire ça en
politique ouais j'aurais voulu qu'on
prenne pendant toute la campagne
électorale
et puis on dit écouter ce qu'il a dit at
elle info ou intox
écoutez là ça ce serait formidable
et toi de quelle émission études jaloux
à moi je suis je suis pas jaloux mais
j'aurais voulu inventer l'école des fans
sur les douze que pour mettre un peu
d'ordre dans ce débat je vais demander
au professeur rollin de resituer le
débat s'il vous plaît oui je crois qu'il
est en effet utile de resituer un petit
peu les choses parce que derrière cette
question en apparence très complexe se
situe à un débat qu'on peut en fait
résumé assez simplement je voudrais
juste avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet présenté mes excuses à nos amis
téléspectateurs parce que je me suis un
petit peu emporter la semaine dernière
j'ai piqué une colère j'ai pété un plomb
comme disent les jeunes il faut dire que
j'avais des raisons j'ai dit que
l'émission était bâclé et c'était vrai
il était bâclé vous l'avez reconnue vous
même par l'afrique mais enfin bon
passons là dessus c'est vrai que je suis
sorti de mes gonds et je sais que ça a
choqué un certain nombre de gens il ya
eu toute une série de lettres pour s'en
émouvoir j'ai par exemple ici une lettre
de madame dominique cauchy de malakoff
qui me dit il y a déjà trop de violence
à la télévision n'en rajoutez pas et
c'est vrai c'est vrai même si c'est dit
sur un ton un petit peu péremptoire un
choix mal au nom de quoi cette dame
vient de donner des leçons elle me fait
la morale là du haut de son mètre
cinquante
enfin si ça se trouve elle est dix fois
plus violente que moi dans sa vie
quotidienne si ça se trouve elle tape
sur ces gosses avec un gourdin et un
grand saint julien et bevand ça aurait
dit alors vous vois mal de quel droit
elle vient de critiquer mais enfin bon
personne ne les oblige à regarder double
chose qu'elle n'aime pas ça n'est ce pas
cette grosse truie n a qu à l ess
contient
la violence elle vient pas de moi ici n
ya pas de moi vous le savez très bien
batié là avec son bâti chaud il est
mille fois plus violent quoi ça devant
lui personne ne me dit rien et puis moi
dès que je lève le petit doigt
j'ai vingt-cinq mille rabat joie qui me
tombent sur le râble il n'y a ni
gnagnagna c'est trop violent on est
choqué ça commence à bien faire ce
cinéma moi je viens ici trop qui font
parler de fibre optique 1 et puis on
commence à faire mon procès publiquement
ça va bien cette histoire je vais pas
rester là quand même au vélo à peu faire
d'évoluer avec minimum d'actes de bons
petits cratères méchant car tiaret wada
jackson
ouais ouais
[Musique]
roady mois le 13 juin
tu faisais des adieux en 13 juin tu vois
que d'avoir des emmerdes pour un truc
comme ça j'attends c'est vrai que c'est
ça on sait mais c'est bien parce juin le
13 juin
tu faisais des adieux à tf1 et tu disais
que tu en avais marre du parisianisme
copain-copain enfin je ne sais quoi
salle parisienne une copains copains des
copains dans ce boulot toi non non c'est
vrai que j'avais envie sinon j'avais
surtout envie de me vider la tête
d'aller de l'autre côté de la télévision
alors c'est un luxe que je me permets
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
devraient le faire et qu'ils ne font pas
parce que tu penses à quillan par
personne en question qui aurait tout
allait bien tu étais dans ta bastide
corrézienne way est et 2 autres lotoise
et d'un seul coup
quoi tout va mal tout va mal depuis le
début de match et pas d'un seul coup tu
monte à paris lé avec ta mercedes pour
la conciliation avec fanfan 530 km dans
un sens un sens à ta voix si oui dollars
y est surfant frange été discret thurman
et et en rentrant poule tu sors de la
route
ouais ben ça arrive tu était bourré non
ça va pas aller passer le volant à sacha
il y avait personne à côté 1 s'annonce
et je suis parti en aquaplaning et alors
là là tu commences à faire des photos
pour match les ecchymoses l'arcade
sourcilière pas faire la bagnole
alors est-ce que c'est pas du
reality-show cfi si tu vois et après je
m'en suis voulu bon et j'ai plus d'une
ville
je m'en suis pas aperçue sur le coup tu
sais on le sait un piège
les journaux parce qu'on a des copains
dans les journaux je veux dire pourquoi
on a des copains on a des copains dans
les journaux comme match comme france
dimanche france par ici dimanche parce
que on maîtrise mieux ce qu'on écrit sur
nous si les gens s'imaginent que quand
il paraît un truc dans un journal on
n'est pas d'accord c'est pas vrai
souvent on est d'accord il enjolive à
leur manière on a des copains et la
manière ça ne veut pas trop revenir
dessus mais quand on a un drame
la seule manière que ça nous échappe pas
trop c'est participer avec eux parce que
si on participe pas du tout si on se
braque contre eux là ils écrivent ils
écrivent des vrais conneries alors tu
joues un peu le jeu et puis ça a été
vraiment tu regardes tu t'aperçois tu
dis mais finalement je suis en train
d'en faire du reality show et c'est fini
voilà je ferai plus tu feras plus non le
moins possible mais j'ai vraiment je le
ferai plus et puis il ya eu cette
histoire de médailles qui m'a beaucoup
fait rire que tu arraches au moment de
l'accident
parfois c'est quoi alors mais quitte
avait donné cette médaille c'est une
dame qui m'avait donné cette médaille
c'est une médaille tu sais je suis un
vieux cers je suis un vieux superstition
alors j'ai médaille au cumul qui était
composé d'une croix qu'elle nous dira
catholique d'une croix d'une d'un
croissant vrai musulman et d'une étoile
de dérivés étoile de david 1 et 7
étoiles on lui avait donné pour 30 et ne
put jeu léché les emmerdements
je suis quelqu'un je suis quelqu'un
d'assez subversif effectivement parce
que dans ma vie s'est trouvée qui a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de choses des dates je
suis superstitieux sur les dates
il ya des choses qui m'échappent que je
comprends pas tu vois par exemple juste
avant mon accident de voiture se jure
que c'est vrai j'étais sur la route sur
l'autoroute et j'ai écouté une cassette
de radio et tout d'un coup ma cassette
s'est arrêtée et la radio est passé par
dessus et il ya eu un flash de radio il
ya eu ni j'ai entendu une fille c'était
radio
vierzon je sais pas quoi qui disait
attention orages sur vierzon et ça
n'arrive jamais voilà et dix minutes
après je me suis cassé la gueule sous
l'orage
je ne sais toujours pas pourquoi 7,7
il ya eu cette espèce de l'avertissement
il ya plus cette médaille maintenant
j'ai jeté ouais non mais c'est contre
c'est comme toutes les superstitions tu
l'interprète comme tu veux c'est
peut-être j'ai eu tort peut-être j'ai eu
raison
je ne sais pas angeli et les
superstitions sur piaf c'est quoi c'est
très délicat
c'est un truc de fou il se trouve que
chaque fois que j'ai eus edith piaf dans
ma voiture par exemple j'ai écouté les
cassettes il m'arrivait que des merdes
et ça c'est un truc tu sais c'est un
truc ce que je vais le dire ça va te
paraître très bizarre ils piaffent qui
était quelqu'un de mystique quand même
un petit peu un et j'avais jeu mais
j'écoutais piaf j'ai eu un accident de
voiture et pour quelqu'un qui m'est
rentré dedans tu vois un feu et puis
j'ai fait la relation de cause à effet
j'ai jeté la cassette et après je me
suis dit c'est trop con comment tu vas
pas géré cité l'inversé prendre j'ai
racheté la cassette j'ai fait dix
matches j'ai éclaté les capte tu vois
et il ya eu plein plein de choses comme
ça
un jour j'ai raconté ça un rôle qu'est
qu'ils aient une émission sur europe 1
il ya quatre personnes qui ont appelé en
disant ça nous est arrivé aussi à cause
des 10 à fin à cause des dix pires
tronçons parenthèse a proposé 10 capes
ce qui fait que maintenant je fuis tu
vois des gens tant ils sont edith piaf
je crois je tourne dix mois alors tu as
tourné là sans hésiter piaf dans la tua
commence quand on nature park ans alors
je suis je suis parti cet été alors ce
que j'aimerais c'est que je m'éclate
parce que je suis parti je voulais
amener quelque chose de nouveau dans
l'imitation parce que des limitations
bon je sais faire des imitations
j'ai vraiment envie de monter sur scène
géniale je m'éclate revend et j'ai pris
des transformistes qui sont une troupe
qui s'appelle les aristocrates qui sont
des mecs des jeunes mecs qui se déguise
en adjani en michael jackson dont simone
marilyn monroe et cetera prises et ça me
permet de les intégrer dans mon
spectacle moi de sortir et de me
déguiser et de me faire dialoguer par
exemple depardieu avec avec adjani de
faire dialoguer signoret avec
avec marilyn pour qu'il règle ses
comptes de faire dialoguer le pen avec
jackson et ça fait tout un spectacle ça
fait toute une grille cdu c'est du vrai
spectacle
tu vois tu repars la highway je remporte
je suis content je remets tu peux pas
savoir je revis moi sur scène en fait je
crois que tu fais pour ça alors c'est
vrai que la télé beaucoup plus de blé a
gagné mais je suis mal je l'aï manqué
une bouffée d'oxygène et je fais
l'olympia au mois deux mois de janvier
avec avec ces mecs là avec ses bons et
bien d'un doublé ça va ouais j'en ai
j'en ai jusque c'est alors j'en ai
suffisamment pour prendre le luxe de
m'arrêter de faire de la télévision
pendant pendant un moment parce que je
suis pas accro ya des mecs à la télé qui
sont accros à ça et qui continuent à
agir de la télé il ya des mecs qui sont
venus à faire de la tmp trc les mêmes
que le notaire qui font de la télé qui
n'ont plus grand chose à y dire tu vois
qu'ils ont tous qui est alors toute
chaîne toutes chaînes confondues et
toutes les unités toutes chaînes
confondues
et en plus il est beau temps tu dis moi
alors le village et a grandi là je vais
la cré ont remis une plaque me suis dit
des amas maintenant c'est bien non ça
que ça faisait plaisir à maman et
voulait qu'on marque enfin la plaque je
les découvertes c'était dans cette
maison j'ai vécu mes plus belles années
parce que c'est vrai que parce que
c'était vachement à l'arrivée de l'adq
est venu c'est mon prof te lasser un
ministre et ministre des affaires
sociales et c'est mon prof de maths à
l'époque où il y avait un mec du rpr
aussi comment il s'appelle aubert dont
québec sauveur mais parce que chirac
n'avait pas pu venir
il ya françois hollande qui est venu
ouais tu vois c'est parler mais des mecs
de gauche dvg droite il y avait sur demi
terrain je cligne des yeux pour me
regarder le nombril de l'intérieur je
suis tellement pris six mois je n'ai pas
envie de te lancer dans la politique
ah non ah bon je sais qu'il ya pas mal
de de gens de télé qui sont lancés dans
la politique américaine il ya ma mère il
ya baudis verser dans ses dribbles
absolue il y en a un où tu veux voir
sabatier team à dire si c'est de la
fraude si ces deux là je vous aime
profondément à tous je fais le discours
pour le papier merveilleux je ne le
ferai pas je voudrais dire ce soir à
vous ou à la caméra
permettez j'aimerais bien dire à tout le
monde combien je suis heureux de faire
de la politique ce soir je vais créer le
mouvement du allez-y j'aimerais
tellement être président du alesi ça
fait un peu formule mais il ya déjà un
président du sénat ce serait vachement
bien aller politique
traqueur allez prends ton petit
téléviseur
ouais ça va ouais tu imagines divisant
la police on regarde en avril dernier
l'écran de l'a5 c'est un défi nitivement
cinq mois plus tard jean claude bourret
nourrit toujours l'espoir de faire
revivre la défunte chaîne cette
opiniâtreté marque la carrière du
journaliste tout petit il s'identifie à
tintin et fantasio et aspirons ses
reporters naïf et au grand coeur font
naître en lui la vocation d'un certain
journalisme
après des études brillantes il entre à
france inter en 1967 il rejoint tf1 où
il présente le journal télévisé en 1975
p fr actualités jean claude bourret sa
popularité ne cesse de grimper
il est vrai que ce gendre idéal met une
touche d'honneur à ne pas paraître plus
intelligent que son public jean claude
bourret se fait alors le chantre de la
médecine naturelle des régimes
amincissants des ovni ou encore des
gendarmes
m
avec une telle notoriété celui qui ne
cesse de lutter pour la résurrection de
l'a5 brigue aujourd'hui une carrière
politique à l'instar de plusieurs de ses
confrères est depuis longtemps une ombre
plane sur ce parcours presque parfait
jean claude bourret aurait été mêlé à
l'assassinât du petit philippe par
patrick henry
c'était en 1976 la sphère avait
d'ailleurs défrayé la chronique
alors jean claude bourret suivra-t-il la
trace de dominique baudis michel
péricard ou noël mamère
rien n'est moins sûr
a participé à l'assassinât du petit
garçon kidnappé par patrick henry
est-ce de l'info s de l'intox à vous de
chercher on met su dissiper comment jean
claude bourret a participé à
l'assassinât du petit garçon kidnappé
par patrick henry est un piège de la
zone attaque pendant que vous
réfléchissez ici pendant que vous
réfléchissez chez vous qu'est ce qu'on
écoute corti
non
ouais
silverman
arts de la rue savez vous ce que
j'écoute j'écoute ma cocody
applaudissent avec vos paluches pour
accueillir collis à l'excellent matin on
apprend que madame claude
madame claude donc était la reine des
[ __ ] peut dire paris aussi comment tu
le sais bien faire je ne subis pas bon
et bien là madame claude donc bêta
destinée
on n'échappe à sa destinée elle est
encore dans une maison close mais cette
fois il s'agit d'une prison en effet
elle est en prison madame tall qui
avaient été connus très connue sous
pompidou
mais évidemment on ne sait pas ce
qu'elle faisait sous des piles mais
alors le matin maintenant cette petite
information dans le matin pour finir
c'est que aux états unis merci pour le
matin aux états unis un porteur de sida
aussi positif
incidemment si je peux dire dans une
rigolade avec un coeur face à c'est un
truc dont on peut rêver moi je n'ai pas
malheureusement mai
il a craché sur quatre flics et il a
donc été accusé pour coups et blessures
avec intention de donner la mort c'est
quand même pas mal et il s'est contenté
de cracher ci leur avait été sonné je
vous dis pas c'était clair épais et bien
aujourd'hui déclarations extrêmement
importante du parti communiste français
dans l'excellent l'humanité je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas mais sinon l'humilité
dont l'humanité donc journal jeunes avec
une bande rose avance et un rouge un
petit peu alors le fait d le pc le parti
communiste alors le pc ils ont dit je ne
veux pas le pc a dit nous ne voulons pas
pardon de disneyland en france eh bien
ils l'ont dit et ça ne fait rien
résultat de l'opération ça ne va changer
exactement rien ça nous fait rien merci
quand même d'avoir parlé ça nous a
distraits dans l'excellent parisien et
en couleurs [ __ ] donc et en couleurs
brigitte bardot on apprend que brigitte
bardot a adopté un mouton vous savez
qu'elle cherchait un mari déjà là
moutons on est tranquille on est assuré
on sait qu'il passera l'hiver au chaud
évidemment le mouton ça sent mais il va
s'habituer 1 dans l'excellent le monde
d'ailleurs dans tous les journaux par
les siens c'était le problème des
ressent voyez-vous air s'en vient
d'acheter son 31e journal
c'est ça tu dis chiche des conneries et
évidemment c'est interdit mais lui il
s'en fout rina du la paire alors si
rouler ce qui est plus le plus
formidable de tous c'est qu'il a déclaré
qu'il n'avait rien à déclarer il faut
d'ailleurs les journalistes ont
seulement leur piquent les travail mais
en plus il ne fait pas beau c'est on a
demandé
à la plaine ce qu'il en pensait il a dit
moi je suis commerçant
a participé à l'assassinât du petit
garçon kidnappé par patrick henry
s-21 faut s de l'intox michel denisot à
toi de jouer
je pense que c'est un homonyme si tu
t'es mouillé à ce point là c'est un
homonyme
donc c'est quoi de la foule l'intox
formulé comme ça ça peut être de l'info
si c'est un homonyme
je peux pas accepter ce très bon
subtilise info ou intox
jeudi à toc sinon oui parce que le jean
claude bourret contre lui ouais donc tu
dis que c'est de l'intox
ce jean claude bourret de la télé c'est
de l'intox d'accord françois de closets
tête de la flotte
patrick sébastien ça dépend ça dépend de
ce qu'on se contente encore participer
moi je vais te dire un faux parce que
vous êtes assez vicelard pour avoir
trouvé un truc bizarre sur cette affaire
là j'avais un copain qui s'appelle
patrick henry qui était journaliste qui
est journaliste à france dimanche qui
avait loué une chambre dans la dans la
vie vous ça s'est passé qui rentre chez
d'une soirée qui a vu à la télé on a
retrouvé le corps dans la chambre de
nommer patrick henry ouais donc tu
connais bien la faire tu veux nous faire
je connais bien a fermé alors c'était un
sujet qui nous a été envoyé par monsieur
corps tu as donné sous voies qui gagne
déjà 2000 francs puisque le sujet était
tournée maintenant pour savoir si je
vais rajouter mille francs pour savoir
s'il est arrivé à tromper patrick
sébastien bon écoute
la réponse est bien c'est
malheureusement vrai et je dois dire que
j'ai découvert ce drame
à l'occasion du procès c'est en défens
regardant la première chaîne de
télévision sur laquelle je présentais le
journal télévisé que patrick henry le
ravisseur a étranglé son petit otages
cela m'a incité à être encore plus
responsable dans mes propos car à la
télévision avec un mot on peut faire
rire mais avec un mot on peut aussi tuer
le ministère de l'intérieur vient de
nous donner il ya quarante minutes
l'autorisation de vous raconter ce qui
s'est passé le petit philippe bertrand
âgé de 7 ans a été enlevé alors qu'il
revenait chez ses parents peu après sa
sortie de l'école à midi et à ce moment
précis en attendant ces paroles que
patrick henry affolés et trembler le
petit toit tu va les traiter de l'intox
doivent déjà tu marques pas de quoi
ouais c'est pas comme psg s'est fait de
la responsabilité qui lui arrivait
toi aussi par contre toi qui est dit que
c'était de l'info je pensais que c'était
plus vicieux que ça de votre part sur
essai mais c'est c'est vrai que
participer c'est peut-être un mot un
petit peu c'est lui qui veut dire ouais
c'est pas pour ça que c'est le bon mot
mais c'est vrai et fort le bon comme
corti le score en france la première
ligne panique paris saint germain et
puis à revoir le national dans l'espace
et donc pas tout sébastien
de plus à 0 denisot 0 et j'accueille
maintenant michel denisot
monsieur denisot sans vous commandez
vous m'avez tat les dimanches
ben oui c'est télévision sur toutes les
télés moi j'y suis à la télé alors pour
éviter comme sa fille se rende en plus
et puis pour le coup je suis sûr qu'il
va pas dire du mal de moi bah non il
pourra pas il faudra pas dire du mal de
moi puisqu'il faut pouvoir aller filmer
dans les coulisses les autres télés et
ben il peut pas dire du mal
alors voilà c'est comme les critiques
gastronomiques quand ils payent pas
édition ils sont obligés de dire que
c'est bon bon j'ai gaffé non encore un
peu trop bon ben tant pis j'aurais mieux
rien changé à leur insertion dans soir
tu arrives à l'émulsion on peut répondre
ouais bah répond ouais elle sous-entend
donc pour avoir accès aux coulisses de
la télévision on est obligé de dire du
ne pas dire du mal on montre simplement
les choses telles qu'elles se passe il
ya trente six façons de faire la télé on
s'est un peu vos connaissances à peu
près tous toutes les recettes
il ya des façons provoque comme tu fais
avec ce sont des façons spectacle il ya
des façons promo qui sont des fans
d'autres façons il ya des façons
journalistes de base qui sont celles
qu'on fait simplement qu'ils sont là
pour informer
ça veut pas dire qu'on dit du bien et
c'est pas parce qu'on dit du mal qu'on
n'est pas créée qu'on ne dit pas de mal
qu'on n'est pas crédible
on rencontre tout simplement voilà bah
ouais très bien alors cette émission
télé dimanche c'est déjà un succès on
peut dire non c'était très bien
accueilli pour l'instant savez vous
démarrez gentiment fait très bien non
mais faut le dire tu peux le redire
alors bon mais je vais dire je lis la
bourse et bien sûr n'est pas rater c'est
tous les dimanches de 12h35 à 13h30 sur
canal sans décodeur une bonne idée à
l'hebdo télé as une idée simple on
apparaître et on n'a rien inventé
simplement l'adaptation la télévision
des hebdos télé qui existent et qui ont
du succès qui marche depuis longtemps
c'est bien de montrer l'envers du décor
est ce qu'un jour on verra l'envers du
décor de canal de télé dimanche pour
commémorer ces faits déjà ça va passer
dans culture pub
ah bon son gestionnaire rapidement tabac
ils sont plus rapides que moi un an tu
as dit effectivement que c'est un
produit très spécifique canal parce que
vous jouissez d'une sorte de neutralité
pour canal c'est un peu là la suisse du
paf quoi c'est à dire que les plaques la
cuisse du pop et les hauts-de-seine
c'est pas le roi
mais c'est vrai donc comme disait
chantal et comme tu nous le justifie à
l'instant c'est vrai que c'est pour
pouvoir les films et vous êtes obligés
d'être sympa avec les mecs quand même
non oui mais on montre les choses telles
qu'elles sont là j'ai une équipe qui
filme en même temps dans les coulisses
j'ai participé à une autre émission la
semaine dernière je fais pareil on
montre comme c'est à dire qu'il sait pas
c'est pas la caméra cachée
c'est pas non plus de la promo on montre
les choses telles qu'elles sont lire
c'est une forme de journalisme que l'on
pourrait dire anglo saxon qui en france
nous paraît toujours un petit peu
bizarre mais qui va même la base de
l'information puis un autre problème tu
déclares qu'on arrive à la fin des
années de la forme qu'on rentre dans les
années du fonds je dis toujours ça c'est
vrai je dis pas toujours ça je dis ça
depuis depuis pas longtemps je dis que
tu veux revenir à la réflexion oui je
dis que personnellement mais les
émissions de réflexion je sais pas si
c'est pour aujourd'hui celle-ci est
peut-être une mission de réflexion on
peut avoir un regard sur des émissions
qui paraissent légère et il trouver de
la profondeur mais c'est vrai que je
pense qu'on arrive à la fin du de la
forme et que la télé la pub ont véhiculé
ça et on a mené à ça et qui est un
effondrement des idéologies en même
temps enfin je préfère un truc sérieux
là dessus parce que c'est pas non plus
de ma compétence mais c'est ce que je
ressens en ce moment et je crois qu'on
la fin des on arrive à la fin des
paillettes et quand on parle d'un homme
politique quand on le regarde on parle
plus grandes mains de sa cravate que ce
qu'il a dit c'est peut-être parce
qu'aussi ce qu'il a dit n'est pas très
intéressant mais je crois qu'on a on a
il ya un retour de certaines idéologies
et je crois que si on veut pas être
envahi par les idéologies qu'on n'a pas
envie de la voir
il faut peut-être se pencher là dessus
et donné la parole à des gens qui sont
qui sont des gens qui réfléchissent et
qu'ils nous aident à réfléchir parce
qu'en fait en ce qui concerne les
émissions par exemple vous donnez
l'audimat c'est pas une critique ça tu
sais bien que ce qui tue cette société
c'est qu'on dit oui et machin il fait de
la merde mais ça se vend bien truc qui
fait de la merde mais ça fait beaucoup
de stages les gens qui regardent cambrai
de rentrer dans ce système il ya plus de
critiques où il n'ya plus que finalement
des chiffres en ce moment tous les arts
sont jugés en fonction des enfants sur
55 minutes d'émission doit faire 20
secondes sur l'audimat
ouais c'est ça tu as peut-être marquer
mais on fait 20 secondes sur l'audimat
et on dit
mercredi c'est france 2 qui a battu ou
qui est devant de france 3 tf1 si j'en
sais rien mais vous dites pas il a battu
grâce à une émission pourris ou grâce à
une bonne émission
non on rencontre mais c'est là où c'est
pas du fond c'est rendre rendre compte
c'est la base de la formation et je sais
que ça dérange beaucoup en ce moment on
vit plus sur les rumeurs sans vérifier
les infos balance des trucs n'importe
quoi et ça fait mousser ça fait plaisir
au public
mais si c'est faux c'est grave non on
dit des choses justes
il savait combien d'audience et ça fait
ça fait aux alentours de 10% de part de
marché ce qui pour canal+ est une erreur
et un bon score de mécontents oui enfin
si on met ça en jeu toutes les semaines
c'est comme le foot a justement cette
controversée
alors quand vous avez signé vous
espériez 16000 spectateurs à chaque fois
et les dernières et l'objectif c'est
d'en faire des amis les vous en êtes à
30000 ou est autour de 30 milles mais
enfin ça le public peut partir assez
vite partout pour l'instant il est là
les fidèles on avait un peu près de
vingt mille abonnés ce qui est
effectivement une bonne chose
ces premiers du championnat alors qu'il
est peut-être way
figaro télé a dit cette semaine que tout
ce que tu es fleuret se transformer en
or des fleurs je sortir ma vie renaît
alors tv dimanche psg ton vin bientôt ce
sera du mouton rothschild non c'est la
bouteille c'est un vignoble c'est un
vignoble
à la lisière de la touraine à valence
est qui étaient deux hectares de vignes
pas fait d prendre un peu la mode ça
parce qu'il ya quand même deux par dieu
il ya carmelia pivot il ya tigana ça me
gêne pas
c'est la plus tous les gens que tu cites
je les aime bien ça me tente pas de
faire la même chose que je n'ai pas fait
ça par mimétisme je veux avoir plaisir
ça va ma région natale c'est pas pour
gagner des ronds je vais pour
commercialiser sa demain quand même ça
va être commercialisé deux hectares de
20 de ces cons mais ça fait de
bouteilles
ah non ça va faire ça va huit mille
bouteilles à l'hectare seize mille
bouteilles
c'est quand même signé un accord avec
accord pour nom mais ça c'est dans cet
excès un peu rapidement dit non non et
non il ya un restaurant qui veut faire
une carte avec des vins de gens connus
mais moi je sais pas moi qui fais le vin
chez associé avec un vigneron ouais il
lui est spécialiste parce que je sais je
sais ce que je sais faire à peu près
mais ça je sais pas le faire mais ça et
ça me passionne
est ce que dans la région de valence est
là où tu as de son petit deux hectares
là est ce que vous êtes menacés par des
rachats d'étrangers il ya beaucoup
d'anglais qui ont acheté avant
maastricht et mais ya pas de fille a pas
de gros rachats l'un de ces petites
maisons des sections montre un truc là
dessus oui prends ton petit téléviseur
regarde toi aussi francs soit aussi
patrick
en alsace les japonais ont trouvé un
peuple sérieux travailleur et
disciplinés ils ont implanté des usines
telles sony où ricco créer un lycée et
enfin acheter des vignes en 1986 les
nippons franchissent une étape
supplémentaire dans la colonisation de
l'alsace fuji tv acquiert corps et biens
le village de niedermorschwihr près de
colmar afin d'y tourner un feuilleton à
l'eau de rose
le ciel bleu d'alsace avec un seul
contrat la production dispose à la fois
du décor des acteurs et des figurants on
a été choisi le maire a été mis devant
le fait accompli et pour la population
c'était une première qu'on ne savait pas
ce qui nous attend
la transaction entre la mairie et fuji
tv a été menée dans le plus grand secret
les 600 habitants du village ont tous
donné leur accord pour la cession de
leur image de leurs maisons et de leurs
terres à ce contrat de vente établit
comme suit les habitants ont la
jouissance pendant quatre-vingt dix ans
encore deux heures village qui deviendra
propriété totale des japonais dans 90
ans
en outre le contrat stipule que fuji tv
peu disposés à sa convenance du village
et de ses habitants la suite du
feuilleton doit d'ailleurs être
prochainement tourner dans cette
transaction les japonais voit ici la
possibilité de pouvoir utiliser quand
ils le souhaitent
un décor naturel grandeur nature donc il
s'agit en aucun cas d'une forme
d'impérialisme ou de quelques
manoeuvre déguisée que ce soit c'est
tout simplement le sens pratique
japonais seront les les affaires comme
il les mène habituellement fidèles à
leur pudeur naturelle les alsaciens sont
discrets quant à cette initiative
japonaise des propos à leur sujet sont
ceux de la courtoisie ça paie à
charenton et pour cause grâce à cette
manne financière inespérée plus de 300
millions de francs niedermorschwihr
aujourd'hui fleury et repeint à neuf et
le village de plus beau et le plus
rigide alsace voire de france jvh est
complètement un village alsacien s de
l'info est de l'intox alors pendant que
vous réfléchissez ici pendant que vous
réfléchissez chez vous qu'est ce qu'on
écoute corte
chaque année chaque soir pour le chat
et
ouais
b
warren rychel
eh ben
je te jure je boirai plus qu'elle est
elle plus l'avocat quoi joue loyrette
richard m
ok
mais qu'un but devant kate moore
toujours déception
d
mikari bréchet les babines
telco ferry mois vouloir être le chat
peine de risquer
dans tes doigts par mois
et
[Musique]
oui mais
vouloir et brescia 2
et fais moi mal tendre pas
si un jour tu préfère arrêter caresse
les canneberges chien en laisse
tu ne compte pas sur moi pour mes sur le
sofa je te montrerai de quoi est capable
au chat à ce jeu-là jourd'hui roi dans
la suisse et smart one est là
et
m
eh ouais
et
[Musique]
la société
gtv rachète complètement un village
alsacien s de l'info est de l'intox
patrick sébastien à toc toc pourquoi
intox
non non je suis pas voter comme ça ce
dernier en dit quoi j'ai pas voté avant
arrière
non pourquoi t'as pas voter parce que je
pense que je veux pas envie parce que
j'ai ce que j'ai donc tout sauf moi
parce que j'ai pas envie de cautionner
ce système là la nuit sans ballon passe
très vite et contre c'est pas ça c'est
que ce truc c'est pas de la preuve c'est
que j'ai pas trouvé ça très démocratique
avant pourquoi pas parce que ce qui est
les 500 milles d'écart avec qui on
s'amuse ici
bah ouais c'est la démocratie mais c'est
le piège de la démocratie demanda de
klose et la république eh ben moi je
crois qu'il faudrait public la mort la
république à une fois la mort du roi a
une voix n'est ce pas françois
absolument leur garder qu'à une voix
c'était pour le retour du roi
oui miss france lui qui était une
couille juste qui à mon sens oui
d'accord mais tu dis que c'est chantant
j'avais envie de dire une vulgarité
l'histoire de faire pas de vous faire
faire chier baffie cessera dit t'as pas
dit de vulgarité ce soir maintenant si
la vulgaire chicago sied pas d'amour
contrariée
d'habitude si mon chien tox françois
c'est de l'intox bien fou là tu viens
faudrait alors c'était un sujet qui nous
a été envoyé par madame legrand de
chartres est un adjectif 2000 bal
puisqu'elle a tourné le sujet maintenant
pour savoir si elle gagne 1000 francs de
plus on va savoir s'il a réussi à
tromper
michel denisot on regarde la réponse
donc vous voyez bien que c'est
impossible voyez ce contrat était déjà
déchiré je le redis shit et on vendrait
jamais aux japonais par contre ce qui
est vrai c'est que les japonais sont dû
tourner un feuilleton de ciel bleu
d'alsace dans notre village comme quoi
j'ai bien fait de pas voter toi aussi tu
one on comptera 0 1
quant à madame le grand bain est arrivé
à tromper michel denisot bravo madame
legrand vous gagnez 2000 + 1000 égal 3
me
non
c'est bien marc de prépa taïso alors que
de closets dans le même temps réduit
l'écart de sébastien imploser 0 2
niveaux oh la la
et maintenant j'accueille françois de
closets
[Applaudissements]
m
il faut que je vous parle de
professionnels à professionnels en ces
veilles tort vous avez fait une bêtise
ans qui tentait fin pour france 2 vous
n'avez pas tout compris pour gagner plus
toujours plus c'est le contraire qu'il
faut faire
1 il faut passer de france 2 à tf1 vous
avez tout faux là tu leur métier vous à
ce rythme là dans un an vous êtes à
france 3 dans deux ans à rmc et 1 3 ans
et réveille enfin ça qu'on sait que le
voilà maintenant vous en faites ce que
vous voulez a pas bon non sa première
dame chantal ladesou françois allons
discuter tous les lieux on va regarder
le battery chaud tu connais ma fille tu
regardes double jeu est ce qu'il te
choque pas ce qui choque beaucoup de
jambes à pied
mais il serait tellement déçu entre nous
c'est vrai non pas du tout
il ferait une tronche oui il me choque
au règlement donc il y en a combien
quand il est content qu'on n'en ont pas
ils avaient affichant
vous les avez pas peur entourant là on
s'est fait agresser par une dame windham
a pris mon sac à la baule et la moto de
mon frère une harley de 85 ans on
croyait qu'on s'est pas méfié il ya plus
de vieillesse
il avait une canne et on m'a piqué mon
sac a les connaissances et non non non
elle avait 85
le coup de boule de secours et lui a mis
un coup de latte dans les rouleaux
montreuil était rouleau à madame
regarder un gros coup de l'acte d'un
seul coup et puis moi le coup de boule
et tours c'est scandaleux
vous n'êtes pas mis une petite vieille
un tailleur chanel dans les 80 92 21
heures chanel 81 82 ans
c'est souvent attaqués et nous a piqué
le sac et ses bas avec les relais de mon
frère non pas du tout ils avaient une
matraque et ou non mais c'est pas le mec
qui surtout au nom signifie madame s'il
vous plaît en quelle année
monsieur monsieur s'il vous plaît qu'il
a réalisés nous sommes partenaires du
secteur est scolarisé pittoresque dit
oui mais dites lui qui a réalisé 18 dean
norris étant resco la dino risi car elle
est comme ça il me dit que c'est une
horrible sica et on reste aulas
le pape est pas ettore scola oudinot
rizzi dino risi jeudi n'est pas vrai
[ __ ] mais qu'il faut pas taper comme
ça que nous on s'étonner alors arrête tu
vois je veux dire qu'il a fait c'est qui
lui autorise colin d'accord ah bah voilà
là d'accord on pourra les payer une
chopine d'accord là on peut même pas ce
que tu dis que c est quoi cette complète
et winamax débattement et du caissier
torres cola et dis le moi a tenté tout
doute là ça se trouve c'est une autre
vie peut-être longtemps cantonné aux
demoiselles s'il vous plaît en quelle
année noah a gagné roland garros 82 tu
te dis que c'est en 88 blessés l'année
vous attendez la gagne 1,82 et 1,83 en
vain pascal chez ses parents à votre
avis en quelle année il a gagné
[Musique]
ouais
michaud
mais pas sûr que ce soit à 82,1 pour
noël c'est pourquoi je te dis que pour
noah c'est pas sûr que ce soit pas 82,1
doute oui j'ai un doute lors quoi
qu'est-ce qui a passé quatre ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça faisait
alors bienvenue sur france 2 est assez
tu verras c'est très très sympa les
dirigeants sont exceptionnels
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien
on a des trucs à faire quoi michel est
renversant je peux l'avertir de ce qui
l'attend mais ils sont très bien ou très
bien va-t-on des sites g buchs très bien
là je fais joseph besoin très bon très
bien j'ai des techniques et la santé
afin ils sont pas mal non plus très bien
où je suis après tour c'est quand même
très bien on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
tu vas faire quoi au juste là sur ma
chaîne
un magazine dans 4 c'est quatre
magazines en un c'est à dire vers c'est
à dire qu'il y aura un magazine toutes
les semaines
mais une fois ce sera de la science une
fois sera d'environnement et pour le
mans sera deux fois la médecine et puis
un jour ce sera une voix la médecine une
fois l'économie
tu sais comme tf1 maintenant c'est
l'auto promotion c'est oui tu vois c'est
arte y ait un vide foucault foucault
invite drucker ardisson invite de
closets girondins vite peuple et c'est à
quelle heure que ça serait à 22h que
c'est écrit quelque part ça c'est moi
c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit aussi la
semaine dernière c'était 22h48 ouais tu
t'en fous remarques n'ont pas vraiment
j'ai réalisé par semaine à raison
d'environ 10 morts tu as dit nous allons
mettre la france sous haute surveillance
vidéo se dire quoi ça mais ça veut dire
que très souvent on se promène et puis
tout d'un coup on voit un truc aussi pas
vrai c'est abominable c'est dégueulasse
dans le paysage est maintenant souvent
les gens au caméscope aujourd'hui
écouter un vous prenez vous filmer alors
cette saleté la construction dégueulasse
cette audition
et puis l'envoyer la cassette puis
gk pas les cassettes les plus
épouvantables on et sélectionnera et
puis on les montre rap dans sauve qui
peut c'est bien cela rajoute trois
points de poètes appel mondial et de
bain en fait il va faire vis de ça sera
vidée au flop
google entre nous françois pourquoi tu
es parti mais trop d'argent sur tf1 ça
fait chier tout ce pognon
tu te dis c'est pas juste je me suis
laissé tenter moi je résiste à tout sauf
à la tentation un oscar wilde qui disait
ça et de faire ses quatre magazines ça a
changé complètement de ce que je faisais
sur tf1 là et ça marchait bien ça
marchait bien mais diasio mairie car mes
4 % de part de marché mais oui mais la
durée de 10 ans le dimanche dans son
émission
ouais ouais soyons clairs et simplement
quand les choses marchent bien faut les
arrêter parce que si on dit puisque sa
barque en continu un jour vous quittez
la pièce vous écouter et les gens lieu
de soupirer parce qu'ils vont regretter
c'est bien parce qu'ils sont soulagés
devra partir voiture des trois exemples
de ca 1 michel arrêté zénith alors ça
marche très bien s'arrêter
enfin il ya une chose qui est certaine
c'est qu'ils étaient faits pour faire de
la télé parce que j'ai appris en
étudiant le temps dossier que tu as
commencé à travaillé dans un cirque
oui depuis ça ne change pas beaucoup
j'ai retrouvé ça par hasard
soufflons circus oui une folie c'est
quoi dans ce cirque du tout dans un
circuit léché régulière
mesdames et entre 20 et 27 ans est
vraiment été une bande de copains et on
faisait un point tel que cela françois
cluzet a commencé dans un cirque un oui
non ça c'est de l'info après cette info
on veut toucher honda on a fait des
pièces de théâtre ont cédé numéro de
burlesque des numéros d'illusion ce
numéro de clown à la lumière de tous et
puis puisqu'il se passait c'est en même
temps accessoirement par exemple faisait
sciences po oui je sais et bein oui oui
et puis un jour on m'a dit que
vous voudriez entraîne dans un cabinet
ministériel et je dois avoir été la
seule personne qui ait eu à dire qu'est
ce que je fais cet été j'entre dans un
cabinet ministériel où je pars faire ma
tournée de cirque
j'ai choisi d'entrer dans le cabinet
ministériel
tu serais dompteur maintenant dix mois
c'est à l'époque du cirque te raconterai
tata première femme danièle lebrun
django c'était le premier prix du
conservatoire est pensionnaire de la
comédie française des jeux d'équilibré
alors la deuxième femme janine jossin
était en fait quand tu l'a connu
l'attaché de presse de tennis et ça
c'est j'ai rencontré parce que l naples
l époque je n'ai pas fait de livres elle
m'a demandé mais voilà on dirait que
vous fassiez un vivre en 15 jours et je
me jouer bien essayé à des bons alors
vous signez le contre en verser un
avaloir dit non parce que je sais pas si
j'ai créé et puis bon il m'a donné des
conseils et plus de conseils en conseil
tu l'a épousée et voilà ça a marché
alors dit moi elle est toujours co
productrice d'ex libris
je travaille toujours de lui faire pas
mal de bouquins à lire chaque semaine
non mais c'est à dire qu'il ya surtout
un problème c'est que depuis vingt ans
qu'elle fait ce métier je le serai à
l'express et le nouvel obs il ya tous
les jours à peu près 10 livres qui
arrive dans l'appartement
alors il arrive des moments où si elle
les évacue parent et vite
il faut enfiler lépine dur pour arriver
jusqu'au nid conjugal
ça c'est terry il ya un problème
d'évacuation des 10 en données cas
présent d'abord il devient environs de
temps en temps quand même nom vous dit
des choses méchantes la part des choses
mais c'est infâme non alors tu as dit si
j'avais su que que je deviendrai célèbre
j'aurais pris un pseudo pour pas que tes
enfants et cette image d'un papa prof un
peu mais françois de poser c'est déjà un
pseudo parce que ton venance et
françois-pierre de klose et des rennes
c'est ça oui c'est ça joli quand même
comme louis seulement il faut voir
aujourd'hui les cartes de visite
lapierre de klose et d'airé
et ça tiendrait pas ses familles c'est
une ligne et d'ingénieurs qui était
parti de france après la révolution pour
construire aux ânes des chemins de fer
des trucs comme ça c'est joli oui si
vous êtes une belle histoire c'est
dommage qu'elle se soit ravages qu'elle
se soit arrêtée parce que bon tout ça
s'est terminé par une superbe failli
c'est lequel qui a fait faillite
c'est mon grand père alors dans toute
une vie quand on goût tu dénonce le
gaspillage de l'argent public quoi
finalement
oui bon c'est sûr en terme à l'enquêté
sur france2 pardon de la la il y avait
vingt corps ouais tu fais ça ira pas
alors moi quand je savane jeudi encore
tf1 de la vieille logique justement
triple a sur le gaspillage de l'argent
public
revis prends ton petit téléviseur et
regarde pour contrer le travail au noir
sur une initiative du gouvernement
cresson une politique en faveur des
emplois familiaux a été mise en place
depuis le début de l'année en effet
toute embauche déclaré d'une personne à
domicile permet de payer moins d'impôts
devant le franc succès de cette loi est
en accord avec les directives
européennes le gouvernement actuel vient
de décider d'élargir cette action en lui
donnant un caractère humanitaire
je suis donc en mesure de vous annoncer
la mise en place très prochainement du
net de solidarité que nous avons appelé
allocation de solidarité humanitaire qui
permettra à chaque famille qui le
souhaitent de recevoir en son sein à
réfugiés des pays en conflit
le gouvernement a d'ailleurs mis
l'accent sur l' embauche de réfugiés
issus des pays d'europe de l'est et
notamment l'ex yougoslavie
ce qui provoque de vives réactions au
sein de la classe politique la politique
et des responsables continuent mais je
crois simplement de remarques la
première c'est qu'après la mort de tito
nous avons été le premier et le seul
parti a dénoncé ce qu'est l'espace en
yougoslavie vous avez vu le résultat
bon maintenant ce qui concerne
l'allocation pour les yougoslaves et
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire et ils vont
rester à la maison
ils vont sortir les enfants ils vont
regarder les chaînes vont faire la
penderie non on a des milliers des
milliers de chômeurs en france il vaut
mieux commencer par s'occuper d'eux
cette allocation calqué sur le système
d'allocation familiale permettra à la
famille en question de recevoir une
somme de 1000 francs pour l'accueil des
réfugiés 2000 francs pour de réfugiés
nous allons éditer des brochures
d'information d'ailleurs traduite en
plusieurs langues
ces brochures seront disponibles dans
toutes les mairies et des préfectures
une aubaine financière en effet quand on
sait qu'en plus de la prime versée les
familles des traits bénéficieront de
réductions d'impôts déjà de nombreux
foyers ont manifesté un vif intérêt à
embaucher un réfugié aux jeunes
landaises pour les une femme est
justement des enfants cette chambre est
déjà prête
oui mais c'est notre chambre d'amis et
puis elle sera tranquille parce que leur
alarme pour elle toute seule je suis sûr
qu'on le fait pour l'argent on ne fait
pas que pour ça c'est notre manière à
nous d'aider les autres qui sont en
besoin dans les pays de l'est où il y
des situations trajet qu'on peut pas
faire grand chose sur le terrain mais si
on peut les aider au moins comme ça
cette allocation de solidarité
humanitaire sera en vigueur dès la fin
de l'année
[Applaudissements]
solidarité pour l' embauche de tous
réfugiés de l'ex yougoslavie s de l'info
est de l'intox
pendant que vous réfléchissez pendant
que vous réfléchissez chez vous
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corti
d'après le choc je sais pas si je me
suis mineur du texte mais je peux pas te
laisser dans cet état tout je te jure je
peux pas abandonner mon bébé à humour je
peux pas t'abandonner mon bébé c'est
comme ça débute à 17h
[Musique]
et
à
charest
là
[Musique]
m
tous les clichés de l'ex yougoslavie
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox
patrick sébastien à toc pourquoi intox
intox comme ça pourquoi me poser des
questions intox intox toi moi j'ai zéro
en toi prends des risques là tu vois
c'est les saint nazaire minutes qui fait
rentrer un nouveau joueur je dis un full
ouais ouais ouais
monsieur de klose et alors là attention
parce que l'heure est grave
si ce plan seront crédit chez arte tout
sous toutes ses formes
c'est une image et c'est de l'intox fait
et pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est de
l'intox parce que si on avait envie de
faire face à ce serait bon on va voir
c'est une ia denisot qui flippe
c'est un sujet qui lui a été envoyé par
monsieur normand de paris il a déjà
gagné deux mille balles puisqu'on a
tourné son sujet maintenant pour savoir
si je rajoute mille francs
on va savoir la réponse on regarde on
écoute et je couds tout expliquer
c'était de l'intox
ces deux là
alors patrie tu avais dit que c'était la
dote donc ça va pour toi donc tout va
bien
bon j'en dirais prétendants pour michel
c'est dommage ça soit de la table
ouais c'est dommage ah oui elle a
combien de bois monsieur on va voir
après bravo tu restes avec mou sur
france 2 manuel est président ça nous
ennuie te voir juste passé comme ça et
maintenant philippe corti va nous donner
au score ils attaquent du paris
saint-germain restée muette ce soir 0
alors que de klose et n'a jamais baissé
les bras a tenté de rattraper et
sébastien qui gagne ce soir par trois
points de sébastien
mais c'est faux
excellente idée
on pense à lui tous et sébastien ou bien
chez pas des danseuses des quoi et
danseuses pour votre spectacle
ben j'ai déjà engagé baffie ah oui parce
que bon moi je suis maquilleuse en
attendant mais normalement je suis
comédienne et puis la danse c'est mon
fort quand même temps d'adaptation pour
toute façon ça m'intéresse pas non parce
que lui c'est un chaud lapin faut voir
comment il m'a regardé d'un oeil
maquillé
je me suis dit heureusement que j'ai pas
mis un décolleté sinon il en regardant
il à sa réputation vous savez celui là
ou là des douelles à sa réputation mais
l'éthique femmes de paris les boîtes à
quitter sa ville en bois ton cul de cul
voilà vous savez c'est un très bon
imitateur
mais sa meilleure imitation c'est quand
même pervers pépère à l'epal a dit je
m'en fous
ouais
oui justement maintenant nous allons
nous séparer la soirée terminée
et oui mon père y est oui mon but et on
était bien pour traiter bien tous les
catcheurs
est-ce qu'on était bien mais toi toi
c'est pas fini justement parce qu'après
ce que je viens d'entendre choisir te
faire confesser
j'en ai besoin tu en as besoin rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour double
jeu vers ses musiciens
un trick quelle est la plus grosse
connerie que tu eiffel entame des plus
grosses conneries
une moto j'aurais jamais dû acheter et
puis et puis peut-être une vie que
j'aurais peut-être pas dû choisir je
sais pas peut-être j'ai pas si c'est
vraiment une connerie parce que
finalement je suis quand même vachement
optimiste je transforme les les les
conneries en rêve
finalement donc même si ça fait mal
je m'arrange pour me dire que c'était
pas des conneries enfin par celle que je
t'ai dit m
[Musique]
oh
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux